>> GOOD EVENING EVERYONE WELCOME
TO "THE NEXT REVOLUTION", I'M
STEVE HILTON AND THIS IS A
PRO-FAMILY, PRO-COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO, AN
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WHICH IS JUST
GREAT.
YOU WILL BE SO IMPRESSED WITH
HIM.
I PROMISE.
AND WE HAVE THE START OF A NEW
OCCASIONAL SERIES WHICH I THINK
YOU WILL ENJOY.
>> AN UPDATE ON THE REAR
COLLISION SCANDAL, GET READY TO
BREAK UP THE CHINA # AGAIN TO
LIGHT.
FIRST THE MAIN FACTOR SCANDAL.
POPULISM IS ABOUT BODY A CORRUPT
ESTABLISHMENT AND BOY DID WE SEE
THEM IN ACTION THIS WEEK.
THIS WAS THE WEEK THAT ROBERT
MULDER PUT HIMSELF IN THE ARENA.
WITH HIS BIZARRE NEW DOCTRINE OF
NOT NOT GUILTY HE OVERTURNED THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
THEN IT IS UNSETTLING
IMPEACHMENT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
HE REVEALED HIS REAL OVERTURNING
TO 2016 ELECTION.
HE WAS TIED TO THE NEUTRAL
CONCLUSION THAT THE COUNTRY
COULD UNITE BEHIND BUT ON
WEDNESDAY HE RIPPED OFF THE MARK
AND SHOWED HIM WHAT HE IS A
PARTISAN IN THE FIGHT BETWEEN
THE POPULIST AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
WE SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED, HE
IS THE ESTABLISHMENT, HE IS A
LAWYER.
AS WE TOLD HIM TO GO AND
REPRESENT ON MUELLER AND HIS
BEST BUDDY JAMES COMEY.
REMEMBER ROBERT MUELLER WAS
PREVIOUSLY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
IN JAMES COMEY WAS PREVIOUSLY
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
BY IN INCREDIBLE COINCIDENCE
ONCE COMING LEFT THAT JOB TO
BECOME A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL COUNSEL OF DEFENSE
GIANT.
HE WAS AWARDED CONTRACT AFTER
CONTRACT OVER $1 MILLION WORTH
BY ROBERT MUELLER FBI.
AND THERE IS MORE AS WE TOLD
YOU.
ROBERT MUELLER GOES BEYOND A
BILLION-DOLLAR CONTRACT THAT HIS
BEST FRIEND EMPLOYER, AFTER
LEAVING HIS POST AS FBI
DIRECTOR, WHAT IS THIS
MODERN-DAY STATE, THE SPIRIT
FILLED OF ETHICS DO WHAT?
HE WENT BACK TO WORK FOR HIS OLD
LOBBY AND PREPARED ENTERPRISE HE
IS TRYING TO DIRECTLY RELATE TO
HIS PRETENSE WORK.
ONE OF THOSE IS HAMILTON, AND A
GIANT SURVEILLANCE CONTRAPTION.
HE CALLED THEM THE WORLD'S MOST
PROFITABLE SPY AGENCY.
THAT IS THE ESTABLISHMENT CODE.
YOU PROTECT EACH OTHER ALWAYS.
AND YOU TAKE DOWN ANY AND EVERY
THREAT TO YOUR POWER.
THAT IS HOW TO UNDERSTAND LAST
WEEK'S EXTRAORDINARY
INTERVENTION AND IT WAS THE
ESTABLISHMENT FINAL STAND
AGAINST THE MORTAL ENEMY AND
WHAT HE LED IN 2016.
THEY TRY TO STOP THEM GETTING
ELECTED BY CLEARING HILLER
CLINTON.
THEY TRIED TO BRING HIM DOWN BY
MANUFACTURING A RUSSIAN
COLLISION SCANDAL AND WHEN ALL
THAT FAILED LAST WEEK ROBERT
MUELLER PLAYED THE OBSTRUCTION
CARD TO STRIP AWAY ALL THE
INTELLECTUAL INCOHERENCE AND IT
ALL BOILED DOWN TO ONE THING.
MUELLER SAYING I CANNOT PROVE HE
DID IT BUT HE DID IT, HE TALKED
ABOUT IN THE PROCESS AND WITHOUT
WEEKS OF PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO
HIDE THE EXPOSE OF NATURE OF
WHAT HE IS REALLY SAYING
MUELLER:  CONGRESS AND IMPEACH
HIM FOR WHAT?
HE DID NOT PLOT WITH PUTIN TO
STEAL THE INFLECTION ALERT FOUND
NO EVIDENCE OF THAT OF TWO YEARS
OF TRYING.
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT OBJECT
JUSTICE, MUELLER FOUND NO
EVIDENCE OF THAT EITHER.
HE EVEN SELF-ADMITTED IN A
CONFRONTATION PUT OUT LATER THAT
SAME DAY THAT HIS CLAIM WAS NOT
INDICTING A PRESIDENT THAT
STARTED RECOMMENDING CHARGES,
THAT WAS A LIE.
THAT IS
LEAT IS
LET' IS
LET'SIS
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
ROBERT MUELLER LIGHT FROM THE
PODIUM LAST WEDNESDAY, HE LIED
TO COVER UP THE FACT THAT HE DID
NOT FIND EVIDENCE OF OBSTRUCTION
TO JUSTIFY THE CRIMINAL CHARGE.
WHAT DID HE FIND?
STORIES ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
LOSING HIS TEMPER.
OF COURSE HE LOST HIS TEMPER, IF
A TOTALLY MANUFACTURE CONSPIRACY
THEORY ABOUT YOU BEING A TRADE
OF A COUNTRY INCLUDING WITH AN
ENEMY DERAILS YOUR PRESIDENCY
FOR YEARS WOULDN'T YOU BE
ANNOYED ABOUT IT?
THIS WAS A REAL OPTION NOT
OBSTRUCTION.
WERE GONNA IMPEACH A PRESIDENT
PREVENTING?
BY THAT STATED WE SHOULD IMPEACH
AMY KLOBUCHAR WITHOUT BUSINESS.
AS A WALL STREET JOURNAL PUT IT,
ROBERT MUELLER WANTS AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY TO CHARGE
DONALD TRUMP WITH OBSTRUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS NOT
OBSTRUCTED IN CONSPIRACY THAT
DID NOT EXIST.
A STRAIGHT SHOOTER WITHOUT
BUBBLY A PRESS CONFERENCE HE
SHOT HIMSELF STRAIGHT IN THE
FOOT.
HIS REPUTATION IS DESTROYED AND
HE HAS NO ONE TO BLAME BUT
HIMSELF BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
IT'S GOOD THAT THE ORIGINS OF
THE PLOT AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
ARE NOW BEING INVESTIGATED,
LET'S NOT LEAVE IT THERE.
WHAT MUELLER DID AT HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS NOT JUST JUSTICE
IT WAS A SNEER AT FULL
STATEMENT.
DESIGNED TO CAUSE MATERIAL HARM
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DELIVERED WITH MALICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS?
THE LEGAL STANDARD OF
DEFAMATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD SUE
ROBERT MUELLER FOR ARRIVAL.
LET'S OPEN A CORRUPTION
INVESTIGATION.
INTO THE BUSINESS DEALINGS OF
MUELLER & COMEY AND LET'S
INVESTIGATE THE CONTRACT LET'S
INVESTIGATE THE CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP THAT MUELLER
SWAMPED AND WE HAD A CONFERENCE
OF INTEREST.
THE PERSONAL FINANCIAL
CORRUPTION, LET'S INVESTIGATE,
WHAT'S A PHRASE WE BEEN HEARING
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, WE
NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
IT MUELLER AND COMEY HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG THERE NOTHING TO
FEAR.
RIGHT?
AND LET'S TAKE THE FIGHT TO THE
RIDICULOUS NEVER TRUMP FIRST
LEAD BY BILL KRISTOL JOINING THE
BANNER OF REPUBLICANS FOR THE
RULE OF LAW, THEY SAY THE
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY.
EXCUSE ME?
THERE LITERALLY ATTACKING
DEMOCRACY IN TRYING TO OVERTURN
THE DEMOCRATIC ELECTION OF A
PRESIDENT THEY DESPISE, THEY
TALK ABOUT DECENCY AND OWNER IN
MORALITY.
WHAT MORALITY DO THEY BRING TO
THE TABLE BY THE WAY?
THE DEMENTED IDEOLOGY SENT
MILLIONS TO THEIR DEATHS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WARS IN CUSTER
COUNTRY TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THE PARTY DECADENT BREATH
AUTHORITARIAN DESPERATE OF CHINA
TO THE BRINK OF WORLD
DOMINATION.
IN THE CRAVING INFLECTION TO BIG
BUSINESS TO DESTROY THE
MCKENDREE THAT THE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES.
THESE NEVER TRAVERSED, THIS
CORRUPT ESTABLISHMENT IS ROTTEN
AND HAS FAILED BUT IT IS NOT
DEAD YET.
THEY THINK THEY CAN KICK OUT
TRUMP AND TAKE BACK PART.
DO NOT LET THEM, IT IS TIME TO